-Welcome back, everybody.
As you know, we're always
striving to get better
here at "The Tonight Show."
♪ Harder, better,
faster, stronger ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, before every show,
we put out a suggestion box
for the audience
just to get some feedback
about what you guys
think of the show,
things you'd like to see us do,
that kind of stuff.
So tonight, let's look inside
the Audience Suggestion Box!
-♪ Look into the box,
Audience Suggestion Box ♪
-There we go.
This first one
is from Erica Dennis.
I knew that
before I looked at the card.
Yeah, it's from Erica Dennis
right here.
Says, "Hey, Jimmy,
in the movie 'Scream,'
we always assume Drew Barrymore
is talking to the killer,
but can you show us who
she was actually talking to?"
Well, I did some digging,
and we finally got the answer.
Take a look at this.
[ Telephone rings ]
-Hello?
-Can you hear me now?
-Yes.
Can you hear me now?
-Can you hear me now?
-Listen, ass [bleep]!
-Is this some kind of joke?
-Can you hear me now?
-You've had your fun now,
so I think
you better just leave or else.
-Can you hear me now?
-Oh, God!
-There you go.
Yeah, that makes sense.
There you go.
Try another one. This one's
from Claire Martindale.
"Hey, Jimmy, you should juggle
those pumpkins on your desk.
No cap."
I haven't really juggled
in a while.
So I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, I don't want to...
I used to.
I don't do it anymore.
[ Audience chanting "Do it!" ]
♪♪
I -- I get a little...
I get a little shy.
I get a little shy
when I juggle.
So...I'm just gonna -- Ooh.
I'm just gonna -- I'm gonna
turn around and do it.
Can I get a little
juggling music, please?
[ Funky music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah. Fallon for 2!
[ Pop! ]
Wow. Alright. Here we go.
This one is from Sara Dorfman.
"Hey, Jimmy, I love the
'Macarena' challenge on TikTok.
I also love
horror-movie characters.
Any way you can combine
the two?"
That's a great idea.
Well, joining us now to do
the "Macarena" challenge,
please welcome
Michael Myers, Pennywise,
Jason, Freddy Krueger,
and Ghostface!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Macarena" plays ]
♪♪
-♪ Hey, Macarena ♪
-♪ Ay ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Give it up for
the "Macarena" movie monsters!
Not bad! Love those guys.
[ Applause ]
Uh, okay. This one is from
Ryan Taylor Williams.
"Hey, Jimmy, everyone knows
October 31st is Halloween,
but a lot of people don't know
that it's also
National Magic Day.
You should celebrate that, too."
Actually, I didn't know that,
but you're in luck,
because I just got word that
there's a magician backstage.
His name is the Great Benito,
and we've had him
on the show before.
He's usually pretty good.
Benito, come on out!
The Great Benito! Benito.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ohh! Wow!
Already I'm enjoying this.
Hi. Welcome, Benito.
-Hello. Hello there.
Hello there, Jih-- Jih--
I'm getting a J.
Jih-- Jih-- Jury duty?
-Is this your trick?
-Oh, no, no. No, no. My trick
is much better than that.
-Oh.
-My trick involves this, Jimmy.
If that's your real name.
Take a look at this.
-What is that?
-A small little
glass figurine of a boy.
-Uh-huh.
-A little boy looking out
towards the horizon,
seeing Christmas coming
and maybe the fattened goose.
[ Laughter ]
-He's looking at the goose.
And the goose
is looking back at him,
knowing that his goose
is cooked.
But, anyway, I digress.
-Wow.
-The whole point is --
-Yeah. What is the trick?
The whole point is I'm going
to make this disappear,
and you're not going to know
where it is.
-This is what
I'm talking about.
-Okay?
-Thank you very much.
-You're very welcome. Magic Day.
Here we go.
-Uh-huh.
-Mm-hmm.
[Muffled]
Now, where is it?
[ Laughter ]
Go ahead. Pick a hand.
-Right hand!
-Either hand.
-Which one?
-Right hand!
-The right hand. They think
it's in the right hand.
[ Laughs ]
-Ha ha ha ha ha!
-Not there.
How about the left hand?
-No.
[ Cackles ]
I did it! I did it!
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
Alright. Let's give you
one more chance.
Let's give you one more chance.
You're just warming up.
-Okay.
-I'm gonna put the little boy --
You remember him from Christmas?
-Yes.
-I'm gonna put him
behind my back.
-Okay.
-I'm going to let my hands
do a little something here
and talk to each other
a little bit.
[ Speaking gibberish ]
[ Glass shatters ]
-I think --
-No, no. What?! What?!
-Yeah!
-I think you dropped
something on the floor.
It broke.
I just heard something break.
-I didn't hear anything break.
-Yeah.
-Oh, ho, ho!
My goodness!
♪ It's Magic Day! ♪
[ Laughter ]
Is it midnight yet?
Because I've got to
catch a [bleep] train.
-Alright. Hey, now...
-[Bleep]
♪ Same old game
on the [bleep] train ♪
♪ [Bleep] train, [bleep] train ♪
♪ Same old game
on the [bleep] train ♪
♪ [Bleep] train, [bleep] train ♪
♪ Same old game
on the [bleep] train ♪
-Why are they clapping?
-Hoo hoo hoo!
[ Laughing ]
-Why is everyone clapping?
The Great Bonito, everybody!
-♪ [Bleep] train,
[bleep] train ♪
♪ Same old game
on the [bleep] train ♪
-Thank you. Thank you.
Great Benito.
There he goes. Oh, my God. No!
-[Bleep]
-Alright. There he goes.
The Great Bonito, everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow. There he goes.
Terrible. Terrible magician.
Absolutely terrible magician.
Let's do another one here.
I don't even know that song,
but we all clapped to it.
This one's from Nina Rafferty.
"Hey, Jimmy.
I love the movie 'Halloween.'
Is there any way you could make
a TikTok video based on it?"
Yeah, sure.
Here are some clips
from the movie "Halloween" that
we made into a TikTok video.
Here we go.
-Happy Halloween!
Bye!
Happy Halloween!
Happy, happy Halloween!
♪♪
Bye.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Happy Halloween! Bye!"
We're down
to our last suggestion.
This is from Jim Randall.
Says, "Hey, Jimmy,
I love Timothée Chalamet,
but I have so much trouble
spelling his name.
Do you think you and the Roots
could write a song
that would help me learn
to spell it?"
That's a great idea.
I think we can do that.
Roots, hit it.
♪♪
-♪ Timmy Chalamet
is the best in the game ♪
-♪ But how the heck
do you spell his name? ♪
♪ Just take a sec,
and you might agree ♪
-♪ It's easy to do,
just listen to me ♪
-♪ Timothée Chalamet ♪
-♪ This is how you spell ♪
-♪ Well, first you take a T
then you add an I ♪
-♪ And then M-O-T,
then an H comes by ♪
-♪ Next, you add an E to an E
to match ♪
-♪ We're almost done ♪
-♪ Yeah, that's the first half ♪
-♪ New word up,
so you add a space ♪
-♪ And slap a C
in that first letter place ♪
-♪ In the last letter place,
you're gonna want a T ♪
♪ And that's ♪
-♪ This is how you spell ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's all the time we have
for Audience Suggestion Box.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show"!